hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 9
recap and review Jimmy has a reality
check for Kim Kim has a reality check
for Jimmy and Lalo is the reality check
at the front door of their apartment bad
choice road unsurprisingly has people
making choices with most of them
trending in the direction of looking bad
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched the ninth episode in season 5 a
better call Saul
this video will definitely spoil it for
it go watch get caught up first and then
come back and watch this recap episode
509 bad choice road was longer than
usual so there's a lot to unpack and it
defied the typical shocking event to set
up the ending of the season formula that
works so well in TV dramas Jimmy's
journey through the desert with Mike is
not something he can quickly put behind
him and so the penultimate episode takes
us through the aftermath while all the
moving parts of the story continued to
grind away around him instead of one big
event it was many events and it was a
joy to watch the opening teaser is a
callback to season fours 7th episode
something stupid in that episode we
observed Jimmy and Kim in split-screen
moving in different directions in their
lives the song was the same but the
direction was different Jimmy was making
his way through the PP d process laying
the groundwork for his future name
change as the burner phone business
picked up Kim was going back to work at
the office at Schweikart and Cokely and
putting in time on her pro bono cases
it's the biggest time jump we've had in
the series and we watched as they were
living together but drifting apart in
the teaser for 509 they're far apart
geographically but desperately want to
be together Jimmy is still in the desert
drinking his own urine to keep him going
and Kim is at home smoking heavily
trying to keep hope alive they're a long
way from where they were in something
stupid now a married couple we're both
partners realise just how important the
other is to them in light of the
situation but also now two players in
the game the second part will take some
time to accept but the decisions they've
made have already ensured their place on
the roster in a trip down bad
Road to everyone's relief Jimmy finally
points his phone to the sky and gets
serviced civilization is once again at
their fingertips which means Jimmy can
upgrade his beverage to something other
than his bodily fluids they will in fact
make it out of the desert alive but
first Jimmy has to call Kim he dials as
he slumps down on his knees and holy
hell these kids can act Kim
takes a breath before putting the phone
up to her ear to steady herself but
after a short pause when she hears
Jimmy's voice she breaks and allows
herself to cry after this heartfelt
moment the desert duo make it to a gas
station they get cleaned up get some new
clothes and start to rehydrate while
they wait for Tyrus and Victor to come
pick them up we learned that no one had
discovered the scene of the shootout and
the Gus is sending a crew there to clean
everything up Jimmy goes straight to pay
the bail and while this sets off red
flags with the prosecutors he is able to
get his client released Lalo grills
Jimmy as expected but he sticks to the
script that Mike went over with him his
car broke down about six miles from the
money drop and with no cell service he
had to walk out Lalo tries to poke holes
asking why he didn't hitchhike his way
out but Jimmy's answer that he was
afraid to do so with so much cash seems
to satisfy him for now just as they are
about to part ways and Jimmy can finally
head home Lalo Roxas world by saying
make sure you buy something nice for the
wife man she's a looker huh in the most
Lala way possible he lets him know that
Kim came to see him and Jimmy knows that
that means that she's no longer safe
back at home Kim does her best to
nurture her husband back to health as
he's visibly beat down from this
experience it crushed me a little bit
watching her tend to him while he makes
the decision to lie to her about what
happened well this is a betrayal of
their honesty policy it felt more like
watching a person trying to buy just a
little more time to think their way
through an impossible mess of
inevitabilities he knows Kim has met
Lalo but he still wants to find a way
that it doesn't mean that she's in the
game he lays down the law and says he
can't have her involved with Lalo that
he's worried about her
and that the only thing that kept him
going out there was knowing that she was
there waiting at home she agrees to stay
away from Lalo and asked him if all of
what he went through was worth it he
responds to by telling her to go look
inside the bag there she finds the
$10,000 stacks of money that he earned
for his trouble but she also sees the
second best lawyer mug with a bullet
hole in it this is proof that Jimmy
isn't telling her the whole story but
she doesn't bring it up in that moment I
assume she knows that he's gonna need
some time to recover from this trauma
and probably hopes that he'll eventually
come clean when he's ready as viewers we
have no idea how they'll come out of the
other side of this but we can see that
their love and care for each other is
real the shot of Kim's eye through the
bullet hole in the mug is a nice touch
as she starts to see just how dangerous
everything is around Jimmy at this
moment Kim plans to stay home and
support Jimmy in his recovery but it
turns out he's in no shape to sit still
we learned that he's also in no shape to
tell the truth about what happened when
Kim gives him the perfect opportunity
instead he pretends to get honest
telling her that he had to drink his own
pee like that was the worst thing that
happened while he was gone this was the
saddest part of the episode for me it
just lays everything that's tragic about
their relationship bare kim looks inward
to find the right way to give Jimmy the
opportunity to unburden himself she's
thoughtful and she does it from a place
of care he isn't able to do it and
that's completely understandable on some
level but to watch him pull some saw
like maneuver out at this moment it's
just really difficult to watch after
that we learn he's also in no shape to
be in court
we don't witness what happens in the
courtroom but a DA bills description of
Jimmy snatching defeat from the jaws of
victory is probably all we need to know
from there we make our way into Mike's
car where he delivers one of his classic
speeches where he distills things down
in a way that's level-headed and clear
but in a real way comforting in the
moment of delivery his point is there
will come a day when he will realize a
day has gone by where he hasn't thought
about being out in a desert and what
happened when he realizes he's capable
of that he'll know he's capable of
continuing to forget in other words
we'll take time and he's speaking from
experience and he's not wrong about that
the other point he makes is that people
don't randomly end up wandering through
the desert with 7 million dollars cash
after surviving a shootout choices Mike
and Jimmy made put them there and he
makes a fair point that in the case with
the bandits it was us or them they were
in the game Jimmy's having a hard time
processing he brings up Fred from travel
wire and voices his concerns for doing
all this that they're doing just to get
Lalo out of trouble
Mike agrees with him that there are
problems with the situation with Fred in
hints that getting Lalo out is only part
of a bigger picture he stops short of
telling Jimmy what the plan is but
perhaps this makes things a little
easier to swallow
either way Mike's age advice is the kind
of thing that takes some time to digest
and we'll see later that Jimmy is still
trying to work his way through it Kim
tries to throw herself into the office
and throw herself back into her work but
it becomes clear that almost losing
Jimmy has put things into perspective
for her as she tries to dictate a letter
a framed thank-you note and photo of one
of her pro bono cases catches her eye
before we can even figure out what's
happening she quits the firm and makes
her way out the front door after
grabbing the tequila bottle top that her
and Jimmy scam Ken winds into buying for
them on some level Kim has been
dissatisfied with her job which is
boring and unfulfilled she's made an
attempt to balance that out by doing the
pro bono cases and it's clear here that
she just can't continue doing it at the
same time she's giving up a lot of
security that this job provides a career
that she built through her own hard work
and this is something that will come
back to Mike seems to be functioning at
a much higher level than Saul as we
watch him report in to Gus from the
tattoo on the bandits we learned that
they were Colombians this convinces Gus
that they were hired by Juan balsa but
he doesn't really explain the motives
other than saying he thought he was
protecting their business Mike is on his
way out but stops to tell Gus there's
one more thing for a second I worried
that he was gonna bring up Jimmy and Kim
but instead he tried to get Gus to let
nacho go he points out that they won't
need him anymore that he's basically
served his purpose but Gus isn't moved
he compares not
to a dog that has bitten every owner
it's had and tells Mike that requires a
firm hand or for the dog to be put down
Mike doesn't like Gus's reasoning and he
definitely doesn't like that he
threatens nachos father to control him
by fear but he sees he isn't gonna win
the argument with his boss on his way
out of town Lalo goes to visit Hector at
Casa tranquila the situation the
Salamanca's find themselves in is not
ideal but Lalo tries to spin it in the
best way he can he will have the ear of
Don Eladio when he goes south and he's
confident that he can turn him against
Gus
we learned that Tuco is supposed to get
out of jail in 11 months so nacho won't
have to run their operations for very
long he says he knows Tuco can be
difficult when he's on the stuff but
he'll make sure that he stays clean once
he gets out he tells Hector that family
is everything
and it sort of brings the feels because
you can see that Lalo feels bad about
leaving his uncle alone as he walks out
the door we get this sad shot of Hector
with this party hat on and we wonder if
he's thinking that this is the last time
he's going to see Lalo alive nacho
drives although out to the well where
Jimmy met the cousins he tells them that
he can leave but at the very last second
he knocks on the window and gets back in
the car he didn't see Jimmy's car on the
way in and he can't leave before he
investigates they backtrack and they
find the esteem in the ditch where Mike
and Jimmy left it and after he jumps
down to take a closer look he notices
the bullet hole in the door this
confirms there's more to the story than
what Saul told him and he tells nacho to
take him back to Albuquerque
Kim returns home and delivers the news
that she quits Schweikart and Cokely
Jimmy doesn't take it well and he tells
her that he thinks she's making a bad
choice he tries to tailor Mike's
monologue about choices to the situation
but does a terrible job of it Kim pleads
her case effectively and makes the point
that it's her decision and besides Jimmy
isn't really in a position to question
anyone about their choices before they
can work things out Jimmy gets an urgent
phone call from Mike just as someone's
knocking on their front door Mike tells
him to keep the phone on but hide it so
he can hear what's happening inside the
apartment we learned that it's Lalo at
the door and he invites himself in he
manages to be completely menacing and
still slightly charming
at the same time he wants to hear about
what happened in the desert and when
Jimmy repeats his story Lalo wants to
hear it again this apartment scene is
long intense but somehow it manages to
fly right by Lalo is obviously trying to
catch Jimmy in the lie and he seems
content to wait as long as necessary we
watched as Jimmy's nervousness is just
ratcheting up with each retelling it's
getting worse and he begs for Lalo to
let him leave
Mike enters the scene looking at Lalo
through the scope of a sniper rifle he
has a clear shot but it's not clear to
us whether he's there to take that or if
he's just there to find out if Jimmy's
gonna break and give Lalo information
sensing that this is what is probably
going to happen Kim steps up and lays
into Lalo even though she's probably
terrified of Lalo she acts tough and
pokes holes and each concern he brings
up she effectively turns things around
saying that if Saul Goodman is the only
person you can trust with your money
you've got real problem there's no
decisive victory here it's just enough
to push Lalo back on his heels and get
him to leave the apartment the only
thing that's actually decided here is
that if Kim wasn't in the game before
she definitely is now and that's where
we leave things Lalo isn't done but he
goes to the car and tells nacho they're
headed to Mexico Mike can leave
reporting back that's all stuck to the
story
Jimmy is all sorts of messed up but for
now he's safe and so is Kim but they're
firmly in the game with one Episode to
go so it was a really good setup for the
finale I like the way they took the time
to do what they needed to do with Jimmy
going through what he's going through
and how all of that came down through
Kim it's a tense place that we find
ourselves in Kim's situation feels more
desperate and dangerous than it ever has
and we're seeing a vision of Jimmy where
he may be more broken than he's ever
been before it was a well-crafted
episode and the acting between Jimmy and
Kim just never ceases to amaze me take a
moment and think about the range of
different versions of Jimmy we've seen
Bob Odenkirk do since the beginning of
507 the wedding his first appearance in
court with Lalo his blow-up with Howard
his trip through the desert and now this
I know I don't have to bring this up but
still feel compelled
because they're really hitting it out of
the park this season I was curious to
what the movie they were watching was
whenever they sat down before Jimmy got
up and went back to the courthouse so I
went searching online and according to
Alan Sepinwall writing on Rolling Stone
it's from the classic movie his girl
Friday which is about a woman who keeps
returning to a relationship she knows is
deeply unhealthy for her with a man
whose charm and wild professional
lifestyle she ultimately can't resist so
that discovery was certainly worth the
five minutes I had to spend online
searching Kim isn't the only character
who's ending is in question
it was pretty deflating to see Mike go
to bat for nacho and get nowhere with
Gus I guess from where he's sitting he
has a point but it doesn't make it any
more palatable
it looks like nacho will be traveling to
Mexico by lawless side and you gotta
wonder if both of them will make it back
for sure
Gus will be at an advantage since he'll
have his man right next to his opponent
at this point it's hard to speculate
what's going to happen in this last
episode and exactly where we'll be when
the final season gets started one thing
I was thinking when I was watching Kim
talked to Lalo
there's always been talk about episode
storing the gene timeline and episodes
that crossover with the Breaking Bad
timeline even though I know he won't get
these I want to see episodes that happen
in the timeline before Kim gets to HHM
there could definitely be some
interesting stuff in her backstory
before she made her way to Albuquerque
she stepped in to go toe to toe with
Lalo and that might be something she
learned before she went to law school
it's a little frightening that the
teaser was a mirror of something stupid
that showed them living separate lives
before coming back together at the end
of that season if this shows them
wanting to come together does that mean
that it's before they go off to live
separate lives I mean we know this is
probably coming but with each episode it
somehow gets harder to accept one last
thing Kim quitting her job wasn't
completely out of nowhere but it does
have a big impact on the future of how
the show is structured Kim has existed
on the legal side with the cartel world
with Mike and Gus being in the other
side with Schweikart and Cokely in the
rearview mirror everything in the story
including all the characters exists on
just one side
only one side in the coming weeks let's
discuss how that will change as we
approach the end of the series going
through season six so I still have a lot
on my mind but I'm gonna end it there
let's talk in the comments about where
we think things are going let me know
what you thought about this episode what
do you think it means about the finale
check out the video I made the other day
about Kim's fate it talks about the
possible outcomes based on what we know
from Breaking Bad and other things we've
learned along the way please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon